there's no clear line there plenty of
obese people you know who'd be defined
as obese who are healthy and people who
have normal BMI who are unhealthy hi I'm
Paul Dietrich with reason TV today we're
talking with Abigail Seguin Suki is an
associate professor of sociology and
gender studies at UCLA and has written
the book
what's wrong with fat abigail thanks for
joining us my pleasure okay I think I
can answer the question of your books
what's wrong with fat it's unhealthy
right that is what most people assume
and in fact the idea that fatness is a
medical problem a public health crisis
is taken for granted by most of your
viewers most people watching would
assume that of course fat is a problem
because it's unhealthy in fact it's not
just a problem for an individual person
but it's a public health crisis most of
the books that are published on this
topic will say how have we gotten
ourselves into this predicament
why are we so fat why are we getting
fatter what can we do about it and this
book actually turns those questions on
their head and asks how have we come to
think about fatness as a medical problem
and public health crisis now I watch the
news all the time and they tell me about
this obesity epidemic that's it's the
number one killer is it the number one
killer is it really so I'm not going to
say that there's no health risks
associated with having a BMI over 30
which is the current definition of
obesity BMI is body mass index and it's
bate BMI what we used to measure obesity
is simply a measure of weight
controlling for height I'm not going to
say there's no health risks there are
some health risks the most the clearest
example is type 2 diabetes in which we
see that there is a clear association as
you get heavier as BMI increases your
risk of having type 2 diabetes increases
even that however is an association we
don't know what the causal mechanism is
between higher body mass and diabetes it
may be that being heavier actually
causes diabetes but it could be that
diabetes causes
waking or there could be some third
factor nutrition physical activity even
stress that's causing both obesity and
diabetes there's a difference between
being overweight and being unhealthy
when we talk about an obesity epidemic
we assume that moving from non obese to
obese is like moving is akin to moving
from health to illness right I mean if
we turn Burkle osis epidemic certainly
we're counting the number of people who
have tuberculosis that's clear clearly
ill but with obesity that's not there's
no clear line there are plenty of obese
people who you know who'd be defined as
obese who are healthy and people who
have normal BMI who are unhealthy how
does the media frame our opinions about
fat so I've done an extensive analyses
of news media reporting and have found
several things first I found not
surprisingly that the news media is more
attracted when reporting on scientific
studies to those studies that are
dramatic headlines such as obesity and
overweight is soon to take tobacco is a
leading cause of preventable death is
more appealing and more likely to make
front-page news it's scary it's scary
yeah and it grabs people's attention and
those types of studies are more likely
to get news media coverage than studies
that are less less dramatic in 2004 a
study was published that estimated that
there were 400 excess deaths in the year
2000 because people were overweight or
obese that study got a ton of news media
attention and the headlines were exactly
this soon could overtake tobacco is the
leading cause of preventable death
assuming that this is a choice that
people weigh more another study was
published the following year that
revised that figure down to 26,000 less
than 26,000 it seems it's like more
about the headline than it is about the
what the study said it was about the
headline and it was also a message
we're eating ourselves to death fat is
bad that is taken for granted that
didn't raise skepticism when it comes to
politicians we have the mayor of New
York City outlawing Big Gulp sodas and
salts San Francisco outlawed Happy Meals
where do politicians get fat wrong so
where I think governments and cities air
is linking issues of nutrition and in
some cases physical activity we see this
with Michelle Obama and her let's move
campaign linking these issues that may
have some merits on their own rights to
obesity I think it's a problem for two
reasons first of all by talking about
fat bodies is a problem and we see this
with billboards we recently there was a
wake up Georgia campaign in which they
showed photos of fat children looking
absolutely depressed and despairing into
the camera and they suggested that this
was our problem that our children are
fat what is this what effect does this
have on a kid you know if there are
themselves fat and they look at this it
reinforces the idea that they already
have that they're already being told
believe me by the kids in their class
that there's something wrong with them
here they're being told by adults adults
in positions of authority that their
bodies are not okay is this going to
have a positive effect on them is this
going to make them take better care of
themselves and probably not so if I'm
walking around in New York City and I
can't get a big gulp soda is that an
overreach what do you think my concern
is not so much whether it's an overreach
or not my concern is that it gets linked
with obesity that it's only perceived as
a problem because it's making people
fatter I think that that's
misrepresenting the issue I think it's
dishonest the problem is if we can't
link it to obesity people don't care so
much and that's the problem that the
advocates are faced with if for many
years before we had this obesity
epidemic there are people who are
concerned about nutrition but people
weren't paying attention
they couldn't get people's attention but
because we're all so obsessed about way
linking issues of nutrition to we're
going to get fat our children are going
to get fat
that draws people's attention and that's
why it's being done
I think it misrepresents the issue it
reinforces weight based discrimination
and it's it's a very it comes with very
serious social cost